the fbi is investigating another major
cyber attack affecting a key part of our
economy first
was a major fuel pipeline now it's the
meat industry
13 processing plants in this country had
to shut down because of the hack on
jbs that's the world's largest meat
processing company
it's got dozens of brands in the us
including clear river farms
1855 and pilgrims jbs says the vast
majority of its plants will
operate today but there are still
concerns meat prices could
go up jeff pigues is in washington
he's tracking the investigation jeff
good morning
good morning and this is a big deal and
that is why the white house has gotten
involved in this
early the white house has been in
contact with jbs
a company that says that it was this
victim of a ransomware attack it says
that it took
immediate action once it realized that
its systems were compromised and that
it's doing all that it can right now
to restore its systems jbs
is the second largest producer of beef
pork and chicken
in the united states after the company
told white house officials it suffered a
cyber attack from hackers
likely linked to russia u.s officials
are asking the russian government for an
explanation
this is a national security issue we
have to approach it on that level
former defense secretary and cia
director leon panetta warned in 2012
that the u.s could
face the possibility of a cyber pearl
harbor attack
he says critical infrastructure systems
are increasingly
vulnerable do you think there's a
connection to the kremlin ultimately
i don't think there's any question you
know my own knowledge of
the russian intelligence agencies
they basically operate in every sector
within their own countries and clearly
know
what kind of criminal elements are
involved
the russians know what the hell's going
on in a statement
jbs said our systems are coming back
online and we are not sparing any
resources to fight this threat
we have cyber security plans in place to
address these types of issues and we are
successfully
executing those plans this latest
incident follows
last month's ransomware attack on
colonial pipeline that led to
gas shortages in multiple states russian
hacking group
darkseid claimed responsibility and
walked away with nearly
5 million dollars from colonial imagine
if at the same time they shut down
a pipeline they shut down our food
supply and they turned off the lights
what a nightmare that would be no
exactly and that
that's exactly what our adversaries
would love to see
i mean you know we spend a lot of time
protecting ourselves from these
countries
looking at their military capabilities
we don't spend as much time trying to
defend ourselves from these cyber
capabilities
but make no mistake about it these
cyber attacks represent a military
weapon
that is being used by our adversaries to
try and weaken the united states
yeah and panetta is calling for a
comprehensive
national strategy for cyber defense he
says
this idea of paying the ransom to these
hackers
really sends the wrong message and
encourages them to target more companies
in this case
the concern was that this is something
that could affect the
national food supply and ultimately
raise prices at the grocery store
it is unclear though tony if this
company jbs
actually paid the ransom and also
unclear if they thought they had a
choice jeff thank you very much